here's something that gets on me you're
a couple and you sit down and let's say
you order some fancy shrimp
they should bring you
two
or four
not three
you know what i'm saying it's two you
and your girl
and they bring you three shrimp
that's how you break up relationships
because you're sitting here like okay
it's three shrimps
who getting three
who getting one and then we gotta cut
one so it seems fair
or
why am i dealing with this why not just
bring another one let's say there's
three people
three people three shrimp okay everybody
getting one shrimp
but don't bring five
because now
two people getting more
or one person's having more than they
should and so everybody's looking at
each other with like a hey man you know
you already had two shrimp why you
having another one you know what i'm
saying i don't know if they do this
on purpose
but it's annoying
all the restaurants that do this it's
annoying
bring two for two
bring three for three or you bring
an even amount for everybody on the
table so if there's three people at the
table you bring six shrimp you don't
break five
okay so if there's four people at the
table you bring four shrimp you don't
bring five because now everybody looking
at that last shrimp like who gonna have
that shrimp